chi vi ha passati se non ti vedono
guarda guarda laggiù
[Musica]
green road ice cream si sono alleati
hanno deciso di rinchiudermi in casa
quindi dobbiamo riuscire assieme a
scappare di casa
dobbiamo trovare le chiavi per scappare
ora sono chiuse in questa stanza e
ovviamente tu dovrai aiutarmi anzi sarà
il proprio giù a fare le scelte come
farai a farne uscire da qua
durante il video appariranno 2 caselline
una qui è una qui
dovrai tu scegliere quale cliccare
dovrei cercare di fare le scelte giuste
una volta che sceglierai la casellina
verrà importato un altro video e la
storia continuerà
potresti vincere o potresti perdere se
perdi però potrei ricominciare daccapo e
riprovare puoi anche provare insieme ai
tuoi amici per vedere se sei riuscito
prima a vincere o i tuoi amici
una volta che utilizza il gioco puoi
tornare qua a scrivere nei commenti
in quanti tentativi se riuscito a
vincere restare super attento agli
indizi e magari c'è qualcosa di nascosto
teniamo gli occhi bene aperti c'è solo
una regola importantissima non spoiler
nei commenti quindi non potete scrivere
nei commenti qual è la strada giusta da
prendere
altrimenti che gusto c'è per gli altri
giocatori
lasciate un bps su questo video se
volete un altro video interattivo se
questo video raggiunge i 30 mila mi
piace il prossimo video interattivo sarà
un escape room quindi lasciate subito un
bel mi piace
iniziamo subito la nostra challenge
speriamo di non incontrare subito gray
new road
per prima cosa proviamo uscire dalla
stanza inizio
no è chiusa grandi o roth mi hanno
chiuso qua dentro
quindi la prima cosa da fare è cercare
la chiave qua dentro che potrebbe essere
felice una scatolina con un punto di
domanda è quasi un cassetto quale scegli
sei una delle due caselline